but I do know that if you want that
front pocket carry man you got to get
that Ridge wallet dude Ridge wallet it's
like it really minimizes it's like it
minimizes things you have so it's like
all of a sudden all the junk you had in
your was the stuff you just carry your
wallet in high school Bobby this stuff
in your in your wallet that whatever
with what you find in my wallet
yes remember that [ __ ] I love those with
a mall photos of your friends okay
here's me when I was better looking high
so I have anything in my pocket yeah he
did it no I wouldn't I had no money or
anything
what yeah we just get on the bus I go to
school was a state hospital
well you have to understand that that
back back when I was in high school they
have wallets didn't have all all I had
was um I'll probably have a joint again
in my yeah yeah I was a Heche sure did
really yeah I was a bad dude like MC
Escher yeah sure an artist yeah Bob Bob
was the artist wasn't he who Bob your
brother Steve Oh Steve yeah so no you
guys the same you look like Bob and
that's my point you think we all look
this no you and Steve up the same
sometimes sometimes I can't tell if I
look deep inside of your face I see
Steve I'd be like nothing in common
really we have Anaheim sometimes I feel
like Steve's trapped inside of you
steve is for everyone Bob hyung you're
hungry yeah my brother [ __ ] CEO I've
seen him [ __ ] you know some pictures him
our drawings am [ __ ] oh yeah FDA he
draws his own pictures of him [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's how to drawings and look
one time he was [ __ ] pretty good and
the other one they were resting
[Music]